let's go next to vega
from oklahoma
hey david how's it going it's going well
thank you
um so i was watching the texas democrats
yesterday and honestly it's very
exciting that they got to go over to
washington d.c
yeah yeah so um
what do you think about progress on the
voting rights legislation like
hr1 and hr4 and
also the infrastructure package they
just revealed the
3.5 trillion dollar package today
yeah so uh on the on voting rights i'm
not
hugely optimistic about the bill i've uh
this has been my view for some time and
as as i'm sure you know vega
i would immediately change my opinion if
the facts change
that's just the type of guy i am i'm not
very optimistic on the voting rights act
on infrastructure i am more optimistic i
think joe biden desperately needs
another major accomplishment and uh i'm
hoping
that it is going to um that it is going
to happen hello
yes you're on the air okay oh
sorry sorry your voice went out for a
sec
all right vega thank you very much for
the call i appreciate it lot of
important questions today and glad to
have the opportunity to
answer them let's go next
to oh i don't know how about daniel from
california
also known as ru neugrongler
oh hello david hello uh
yes so like my username nug wrangler
suggests i'm going to be blunt
so when is aoc going to be on the show
i know the possibility was teased last
year shortly after
winning the race to a million
subscribers anytime she wants it's wide
open we've uh we've reached out a couple
of times and haven't heard back
she may be too big for this show right
i'm not delusional
uh but she's welcome absolutely anytime
yeah yeah definitely definitely big um
you know well you're a good interview
interviewer so i'm
sure you'd have an eloquent way of
asking her how she juggles
idealism with pragmatism
and i also wanted to know what she would
have would have thought of
my prediction worthless prediction that
it will be aoc
versus ivanka in 2024. um
it will not be aoc versus ivanka in 2024
but i will make a note of it and ask her
about it in some way i guess if she's
ever on the show
yeah well you know i'm a gambler i i you
know i roll the dice so
that's my bet are you actually betting
on that i mean you could probably get
action on that if you really felt that
was going to happen
you probably got a thousand to one odds
yeah i'm paying a
membership okay all right very good with
uh
illegal discount codes so it's
affordable thank you
i appreciate that all right thanks for
taking my call all right thanks very
much
um listen i'm gonna tell you right now
be very careful with those discount
codes i don't want anybody ending up in
prison as a result of them
one of our sponsors today is strategic
voters a new podcast that features
election experts political campaign
strategists and everyday americans
who sit down and discuss the biggest
issues in the u.s
political landscape on the activism side
strategic voters as an organization
aims to encourage people to vote with
the benefit of the country
as a whole in mind instead of just
voting one party
down the ballot if you want to hear some
really different and interesting
opinions and approaches to voting and
viewing policies
give the strategic voters podcast a
listen the latest two episodes
feature rachel cobb and lana atkinson as
guests i've been listening to it myself
i've been really enjoying it it's very
grassroots and independent which i love
find the strategic voters podcast on all
major podcast platforms and make sure to
follow them
on twitter at strategic voters